[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera
non so voi quanto vi ricordate la storia
antica io molto poco ma quel poco che mi
ricorda grazie a un fumetto asterix che
era un fumetto meraviglioso i
protagonisti andato in giro per questa
antichità con questo júlio césar
isterico lo rendevano al ghana sony
tutti una cosa fantastica
così quando ho iniziato a fare questo
mestiere cioè di andare a cercare di
capire quali erano gli asteroidi che
potesse essere pericolosi per la terra
ea cercare di di prevedere gli impatti a
fare qualcosa e per estendersi appunto
cura di questo problema
c'aveva olimpici pt già pronto perché
gli irriducibili galli avevano paura di
una cosa e cioè che il cielo ricadesse
sulla terra testa infatti quando si
salutavano ci sono ci vediamo domani sì
sì però sempre che c'erano ci cada sulla
testa e poi quello che è successo ai
poveri asteroidi esattamente questo ci è
cascato il cielo sulla testa nella forma
di un asteroide in una decina di km 66
milioni di anni fa
loro avevano dominato la terra per 200
milioni di anni
l'uomo sta qui da credo 45 200.000 anni
un regno incontrastato e arriva questo
asteroide chiaramente non che siano
tutti nello stesso posto del cascato in
testa però ha cambiato causato i
cambiamenti climatici talmente grandi
che una specie soprattutto grande che
aveva bisogno di molto cibo come
dinosauri sia estinta praticamente da un
giorno all'altro
noi come abbiamo fatto a sapere questa
storia degli asteroidi
da qui c'entra un altro strumento messo
un altro fumetto semplicemente perché la
situazione è stato abbastanza in un
certo senso comica mentre l'epopea del
selvaggio west andava verso la fine
quindi c'erano gli ultimi scontri tra
gli indiani cowboy
i banditi tutta la mitologia greca scusa
la mitologia del west c'erano alcuni
cacciatori di fossili dei personaggi che
si era appena scoperto che c'erano stati
questi enormi bestioni che erano stati
sulla terra e i musei di mezzo punto si
contendevano a colpi di soldi quindi
queste erano personaggi molto era è un
vero e proprio business era diventato e
guarda caso proprio in west c'erano dei
posti molto ricercati perché avevano dei
dei dei grandi fossili che verdino soro
lo scrive più grosso e faceva più cassa
come come museo addirittura uno dei
cacciatori di fossili che si chiama
lasciato il suo team march fece un patto
con nuvola rossa il capo desio dicendo
io ti aiuto nelle negoziazioni con con
il governo americano in cambio tu mi dai
l'esclusiva di poter scavare nella tua
riserva alla ricerca di fossili
[Musica]
cosa gli è successo ai poveri dinosauri
ha una pessima giornata e se
immaginatevi qui con voi foste dei
dinosauri a parte le automobili che non
avevano anche in 200 milioni anni non
una veloce nei colori molto però questo
è pienamente quello che gli è successo
ha ricevuto stiamo lì tranquillamente è
apparso qualcosa nel cielo qualcosa che
ha fatto una grande scia poi una grande
luce ea quel punto c'è stato un botto
questo è quello che effettivamente è
successo questo filmato è è vero il
botto è stato per fortuna molto piccolo
altrimenti non saremmo qui a raccontarlo
in questo caso invece di una storia di
10 chilometri era un oggetto di 18 20
metri che comunque ha fatto un bel botto
nel cielo e ci sono stati molti feriti
questo è successo poi per adottare una
cosa molto interessante perché è stato
il primo evento di questo tipo che è
successo in era social con webcam
ovunque quindi abbiamo filmati la rete
più la rete mondiale più estesa di
telecamere mai avuto il riscatto rebbero
pagato qualunque cosa per averla un
tempo e noi ce l'abbiamo praticamente
gratuita questa era un signore c'era la
sua telecamera sono montata sulla
macchina e questo è avvenuto in siberia
il
il 15 febbraio 2013 quello che è
successo e che appunto ci sei sono stati
molti feriti ma non anche lì perché gli
e cascato
l'asteroide addosso quel va alla fine
era un coso grande così andrà a finire
dentro un lago ma perché ci sono state
vedendo questa grande luce nel cielo
la gente si è avvicinato alle finestre è
arrivata l'onda d'urto notoriamente come
il fulmine il tuono più tardi li ha
presi in pieno se non esplose le
finestre e lo si sono feriti nessun
morto però molti feriti
in realtà abbassava che noi avessimo
potuto vorrei dire a quel punto con un
pochino d'anticipo si mandava un
messaggio a tutti non andate da finestre
non scappate per alcuni sono prodotti le
gambe perché sono scappati e la cosa
sarebbe stata risolta
non è andata così diciamo l'unica cosa
forse divertente che si può dire su
questa storia che queste webcam vulcano
anche ripreso quello che è successo a
monzino russo che stanno guidando quel
giorno e questo è quello che ha fatto
allora è chiaro che se questo è quello
che noi facciamo fare siamo fritti e
cioè faremo la fine dei dinosauri lo
stesso
ora però per sapere cosa fare bisogna
che anche possiamo capire soprattutto
cosa sono intestinali con chi abbiamo a
che fare
ora gli asteroidi sono una popolazione
di strani corpi celesti di piccoli ma
anche abbastanza grande in realtà è un
risultato di un frullatore cosmico tra
marte e giove ci doveva essere un
pianeta secondo una serie e appunto di
bizzarria della meccanica celeste però
non c'è e quello che si è visto e che
invece di esserci un pianeta cioè quello
che avrebbe dovuto costruire un pianeta
e che invece è rimasto a livello di
pezzettini
all'inizio si era detto c'era un pianeta
poi esploso e poi ci si è pensato a far
esplodere un pianeta non è per una cosa
che si fa facilmente se noi vediamo
tutti gli arsenali atomici di tutto il
mondo che facciamo
esplode in un punto della terra la terra
neanche lo vede quindi promette che in
realtà non si è formato il pianeta i
mattoni sono rimasti lì girando si sono
scontrati tra di loro si sono
frammentati e alla fine si è creata una
popolazione di rocce che andavano come
quando vi buttate una
vaso di coccio pochi pezzi grossi un po
di pezzi intermedie pochi pezzi e
miccoli
molti pezzi piccole una miriade di
polvere infatti quando poi siamo
riusciti a fotografare
abbiamo visto che per esempio celere il
primo asteroide che è stato scoperto e
quasi un pianeta mentre gli altri sono
proprio i frammenti dei pezzettini
notare i nomi è perché all'inizio si
tutti all'inizio si pensava che si fosse
trovato il pianeta mancante presso il 23
siamo i nomi degli dèi greci come gli
altri pianeti
poi dopo un po sono finiti perché
continuavano a scoprirne e censo oggi ne
usciamo 800mila tra i nostri giovani e
quindi per esempio anche non milano
minciato nomi città paesi eccetera
eccetera ma quando uno ha chiamato un
asteroide come il suo criceto detto no
aspetto ci sono delle regole
i nomi devono essere un certo tipo
diverso c'è tutta una procedura per dare
il nome degli asteroidi tra questi un
certo punto venne scoperto però stavano
nella fascia tra marte e giove era la
terra non lo toccano stavano lì
tranquilli per un certo punto hanno
scoperto il 1898 circa un secolo dopo la
scoperta il primo asteroide scoprono
eros che invece ha un'orbita molto
eccentriche lo porta a sfiorare la terra
e per la prima volta in quel momento
capiamo che siamo a rischio di
collisione cioè che effettivamente uno
di questi asteroidi potrebbe impattare
la terra c'era un altro indizio che ci
avevamo e che ho qui in tasca meteoriti
i meteoriti questo tranquillo e non è
non è riattiva non è pericoloso e un
pezzo di ferro pezzo di ferro perché
viene probabilmente per un pezzo di
farlo speciale perché viene dal nucleo
di un di un di una premete di un
planetoide quindi è successo quello che
è successo alla terra il ferro è andato
emigrato con quando era ancora fluide
adesso noi sappiamo le verranno quello
di ferro questa è la stessa cosa che
dovremmo trovare nel nucleo della terra
quindi cosa è successo a questo punto
noi abbiamo avevamo le tre cose sapevo
che c'era ga steroidi tra il mar
peggiore sapevamo che ci alcuni
sfioravano l'orbita terra sapevamo che
alcuni problemi più piccoli e per
fortuna potevano cadere sulla terra e
diventare meteoriti rocce vaganti nello
spazio ma ci mancava il legame come
facevamo a far cascare gli asteroidi
alla fascia principale alla terra
non si è riuscito a capire tant'è che
per un secolo intero si è la cosa se non
per una cinquantina d'anni
la costa è stato talmente preso talmente
che di meccanici resterà anche di
dominio pubblico
questa incapacità di trovare questo
legame che anche con andò in nell'ultimo
racconto di charlot con la valle della
paura del 1915 quindi una ventina d'anni
dopo che era stato scoperto eros dice
guardate per descrivere l'arcinemico di
sherlock holmes che verso il genio del
male però era un genio diceva scritto
addirittura un libro sito latin sincera
dinamica di un asteroide come si sa cosa
proprio più complicata che c'è alla fine
nel 1980 quindi effetti anche un secolo
dopo la scoperta di eros finalmente si
riescono a trovare
quali sono i canali come se ci fossero
delle autostrade tra la fascia
principale della terra che possono
essere imboccata dagli asteroidi e
quindi diventano a rischio di collisione
non è facile imboccata per questo ci si
è messo un secolo a trovarle ma ci sono
a questo punto ci si deve porre la
domanda ma quanta roba c'abbiamo quanti
sono questi asteroidi che stanno in giro
e che ci potrebbero colpire una cosa
importante da capire che alcuni sembrano
piccoli questa è la distribuzione ogni
ogni oggettino sono vuol dire che sono
100 100 così quindi quelli sopra dal km
quindi diciamo quelli gli uccisori di
dinosauri gasser ogni fine di mondo li
abbiamo scoperti quasi tutti quelli
riempitivo scoperti c'è sempre qualcuno
potrebbe saltar fuori da qualche parte
ma quella si chiama sfortuna però siamo
riusciti a scoprirli quasi tutti però ce
ne stanno sue bordate la parte 100 300
metri è largamente ignota ancora non li
conosciamo non ne abbiamo scoperti 100
300 metri
però sappiamo una cosa che questi
oggetti viaggiano 10 chilometri al
secondo 36.000 chilometri l'ora
ora la differenza tra per un sassolino o
spara con la pistola e solo nella
velocità proiettile come un sassolino e
succede la stessa cosa per gli asteroidi
un proiettile viaggia qualche centinaio
di chilometri l'ora
questi viaggiano 36.000 km ora quindi
anche una cosa piccola 100 300 metri ti
tira giù un'intera regione se non mezza
italia
quindi ce ne dobbiamo preoccupare non li
conosciamo ancora tutti poi ci sono
anche altri oggetti ma sono meno diciamo
più improbabile che succede ci sono
anche le comete che se arriva un
commento né credo che ci sia poco da
fare è poi stato scoperto un paio di
anni fa il primo oggetto interstellare
una cosa molto bella per la prima volta
siamo riusciti a scoprire una stella che
veniva da un altro sistema solare che ci
è passato abbastanza vicino poi è andato
via come si fanno a scoprire gli
asteroidi che cosa dobbiamo fare
continuare a osservare cercare di
scoprirli come si scoprono beh diciamo
la cosa importante sapere che un
asteroide
se noi guardiamo le stelle il cielo si
muove tutto solidalmente ma le stelle
durante la notte le stelle sempre
rimangono praticamente nella stessa
configurazione altrimenti non ci
sarebbero costellazioni cambierebbero un
asteroide un oggetto che invece siccome
gira nel sistema solare come pianeti si
muove rispetto alle stelle quindi
bisogna fare sostanzialmente più
immagini montate in un filmino quello
che vedete muoversi dall'alto in basso
in diagonale è un asteroide provvedere
ci sono anche abb altri puntini che
invece non sono asteroidi sono
imperfezioni della lastra raggi cosmici
e quello che quindi insomma non è un
proprio mestiere facile e soprattutto è
una cosa che deve essere fatta
continuamente noi scopriamo circa 2.000
steroidi l'anno adesso ma dobbiamo
ancora aumentare per riuscire a tenere
il passo
se vogliamo veramente avere un'idea più
precisa di dove sono tutti questi
asteroidi cosa succede dopo che abbiamo
scoperto un asteroide
beh bisogna vedere se il rischio di
collisione non è detto che la sua
traiettoria ci vada necessariamente a
sbattere quindi si fa una cosa che si
chiama si propaga nel tempo in avanti
con il punto con la meccanica celeste
calcolatori elettronici si manda avanti
il tempo e si vede se per caso va a
sbattere
siccome a tutte le misure è associato a
un errore a volte diciamo non sappiamo
esattamente più passa il tempo più la
posizione dell'asteroide sull'orbita in
fieri imprecisa e quindi si comincia a
parlare di probabilità di impatto
e a questo punto è il più difficile è
capire perché ci dobbiamo preoccupare se
c'è una certa probabilità e cosa
significa quella probabilità
continua ogni tanto no appunto quando
escono notizie sui giornali c'è scritto
è stato scoperto questa sera di che a
questa probabilità di cascare intorno
alla terra
mi devo preoccupare o no la cosa devo
dire migliore che mi è successo a un
certo punto un bando rossi toni di
queste notizie mi ha sfidato il telefono
era una mia amica mi ha detto senti non
voglio sapere i dettagli tecnici
devo continuare a pagare il mutuo no e
mi sembra un approccio pragmatico
effettivamente che funziona però le
altre cose se voi vi fate un conto uno
si può fare un conto per esempio lo farà
anche il vostro cellulare si fa quante
lunga l'orbita della terra quanto è
larga la terra e quanto perché
l'asteroide arrivare a incrociare la
terra anche quando la terra passa lì non
è che basta che incrocia la terra
se voi fate questo conto viene fuori una
cosa mi dice almeno 5 1 su 100.000
ma quante 1 su 100.000 allora cominciano
queste queste strane paragoni prendo un
gatto lo butto sul pianoforte
se lui scappando problema 600.000 che se
lui scappando possa suonare l'inizio
della nona di beethoven
oppure cose terrificanti sugli incidenti
che un'altra cosa che tremenda
l'incidente aereo
la peggiore che ho sentito è stata la
probabilità che si venga colpiti per due
volte in un anno da un da un fulmine che
uno dice ma quella non è proprio bella
si chiama in un altro modo
allora provate a cercare di tradurre
questa probabilità in una cosa che io
chiamo la probabilità emotiva cioè
cercare di coinvolgervi perché noi su
questi numeri
prendiamo decisioni noi decidiamo se
occuparci le nostre con noi in base a
numeri di questo tipo così piccoli
no penso facciamo un esperimento mentale
l'orbita della terra e lo è
la ferrovia di un treno voi state
davanti al passaggio a livello siete
l'asteroide aveva il passaggio a livello
il treno passa una volta l'anno io
vivendo vi mettete appello che facciamo
noi non possiate capire se arriva il
treno
vi lascio lì e mi dico avete un anno di
tempo per attraversare questo questo
passaggio a livello se ci riuscite
vi do un milione di euro cosa che in
genere perché naturalmente non ho
l'esperimento non lo farò mai ovviamente
però questa cosa è molto interessante
perché provando lo faccio nelle scuole
molto divertente perché soprattutto il
liceo quando sono grandi si vede anche
una differenza di gender ci sono i
ragazzi e fanno ma dove non vedono l'ora
di avere che sono i veri non se lo
sentono già in tasca invece la parte
femminile è un po più concreta sa che la
sfortuna esiste cercate di ragazzi
guardate che poi se vi dice male bp alla
via il treno comunque è un modo per
capire però questo è effettivamente il
problema come dicevo su questi numeri
noi prendiamo decisioni to mind or not
to mind si potrebbe dire che ci vuole
allora per per salvare di chi abbiamo
bisogno per salvare la terra chi è che
deve fare questa cosa e gli avengers ma
noi come vedete questo è il nostro
gruppo che all'agenzia spaziale europea
abbiamo iniziato a fare questa
operazione quotidiana di prenderci cura
degli asteroidi
come vedete il fisico non ce l'abbiamo
delle m3 questo è fuori dubbio
siamo anche un po troppo tranquilli ma
queste perché probabilmente quel periodo
la facevano di yoga insieme fucka vamo e
poi andavamo a yoga fate una decisa come
fate a fare questo lavoro così dove
andiamo a yoga stiamo benissimo quindi
questo è quello che noi cerchiamo di
fare questo significa osservare gli
asteroidi fare tutto ciò che serve per
mantenere un catalogo e sapere che cosa
come fare in caso ce ne sia qualcuno che
c'ha una probabile un pò dal quart
e se ne troviamo uno abbiamo una
tecnologia spaziale
abbiamo la tecnologia e possiamo pensare
di deflettere effettivamente un
asteroide mandare una sonda dargli una
botta ed è fletterlo quindi diciamo
siamo messi bene ci manca effettivamente
ancora però un po un catalogo più
completo un qualcosa di più
allora a questo punto noi siamo qui in
mezzo al guado cosa fare e cosa non fare
e cosa non fare e sottovalutare il
problema
queste a proporsi sempre asterix che
diceva quando dicevano sempre che c'è
adesso lui rispondeva che cade è certo
ma domani no di sicuro è che è
esattamente quello che noi non dobbiamo
dire perché la probabilità a questa
spiacevole conseguenza che può accadere
anche domani una cosa del genere oppure
tra mille anni però non si sa
l'altra cosa una cosa diciamo che viene
incredibilmente c'entra sanremo nel
senso che quando poi cade quella quella
steroidi che mi ha fatto vedere di
iniziare a due giorni prima di sé ea due
giorni dopo sanremo e nella puntata di
massimo ascolto di sanremo succede una
cosa strana di quell'anno lì due giorni
prima
se potete mandare ho letto che
dopodomani dovrebbe cadere un meteorite
sulla terra ecco tu puoi dirci qualcosa
perché così allora si diceva sì c'è
questa notizia aspetti ma mai ma la cosa
certa è che dato che è stato visto
avvistato se ne è parlato sicuramente
non toccare la terra perché il giorno
con meteorite dovesse arrivarci addosso
non lo direbbe nessuno e ci sentiremo
solo il botto
beh siamo rassicurati pena da quando
dicono che c'è vuol dire che non troppo
bene
[Musica]
il botto è stato non devo dire io vedo
se avremo sempre non perché sia
particolarmente diciamo mi piacciono le
canzoni stati ma perché penso che
vedendo sanremo si capisce un po dove va
l'italia in questo caso addirittura il
mondo andavano gli asteroidi giacobbo ha
detto una cosa che è sostanzialmente
sbagliato ho fatto un salto alto così ma
ha avuto la fortuna di essere confermato
nei fatti e quindi ha avuto questa aura
da profeta direi comunque cosa bisogna
fare invece bisogna continuare a
osservare questo è un telescopio
bellissimo che si chiama fly high perché
come l'occhio di una mosca cercherà di
guardare tutto il cielo per aumentare
ancora non si ha capacità di scoprire e
quindi se posso concludere come si
riassume questa situazione che adesso
cosa stiamo facendo poi c'è un verbo
molto bello in inglese che riassume un
po tutto poi gli asteroidi e perfetto to
rock perché rock vuol dire tante cose
però che la roccia di quel fatto un
asteroide vuol dire anche agitarsi vuol
dire suonare vuol dire ballare vuol dire
tutto questo allora quello che noi
continuiamo a fare il nostro mestiere
[Musica]
grazie